two x squared plus three X minus 6 can
you express it in the fall and then this
is what they give you
right now we have language to describe
this right that first line that's a
quadratic in X quadratic in X but
remember when we looked at equations
reducible to quadratics he said you
can't quadratics in anything you'd like
they're not to be an X this is a
quadratic in X plus 1 that's the thing
that gets squared and then multiplied by
a second coefficient and it is a
constant okay so essentially what they
want is this kind of identity you've got
two things they really are the same how
do you go about showing what the values
of a B and C are okay and this really
really is very similar to trig
identities when we did auxilary angle
okay over here on the right hand side I
have something I can expand and then I'm
going to compare coefficients that's
what I'm going to do okay
so let's work with this guy on the
right-hand side it's not difficult to
expand keep going let me say that X plus
1 or Squared's perfect squares or this
okay
that's just me expanding that I don't
need to do much to the rest now I can
expand the whole lot right and I'm going
to get a series of x squared terms X
terms and clusters ax to ax plus 8 it's
just that expansion plus BX plus B plus
C all right now I'm gonna rearrange this
in a second but before I do that just
look carefully at what we have right I
have an x squared term here it's the
only x squared term in this whole long
list okay this x squared term must
correspond to this x squared term you're
ever when I set all up rattlers uniquely
defined by three points and I said that
corresponds to the fact that it's
uniquely defined by three coefficients
namely these guys right so this
coefficient and that coefficient they
have to be the same guy but that's not
the only kind of comparison
I admit can you see here and here I've
got a pair of X terms right - ax and BX
they're the only X terms in the whole
sequence okay so therefore these guys
must correspond to this stop here and
then what you get left over I've got as
it happens a B and C those are the only
constant terms
they must correspond to this guy don't
forget the sign okay so just to make
that really clear without colors because
you might not happen I'm going to I'm
going to rewrite this in this form I'm
gonna put this guy in general form I've
gone from a quadratic in X plus 1 I'm
gonna write it as a quadratic in X so
here we go there's my x squared term
here is my X term you see that I
factorize out the X and then here with a
brand pair of brackets parenthesis just
how I roll there's my close to turn okay
so now I can say just like I did with
the auxiliary angle by comparison of
coefficients that's what I'm doing this
side and that side
okay I take my x-square my leading
coefficient and I can say a equals two
it has to be it's nowhere else it can
come from right in to a plus B that's
going to be equal to tell me that's
three right and then my last my constant
term over here a plus B plus C watch out
for the side that's negative six
okay so what have we done okay it's not
a problem that we didn't know how to
dissolve it's what we do this is just
three variables three simultaneous
equations and then off you go you get
your values okay
now because this is a skill that I'm
content that you know you can go ahead
and do this I mean it's not even really
three values because you've already got
the first time okay so it's really two
you can go ahead and you can solve that
just like you would normally do you're
gonna get three values at the end this
is what I've got I've got my values but
I haven't actually answered the question
look back at what the questions asking
it says express this in this form I have
everything I need I just haven't said it
you haven't said it so I can say
therefore 2x squared plus 3x minus 6 is
equal at always equal to now we've put
our numbers in two of those - one of
those - seven okay now I've actually
said it that's the formative that's my
quadratic in X plus one